ASUME la presidencia de la nación más
poblada de África y la mayor Economía
del continente
volatinubu de 71 años promete continuar
el legado de su
predecesory
preservaré protegeré y defenderé a la
Constitución de la República Federal de
Nigeria que Dios me ayude
[Música]
volatino búho ha prometido unir a todos
los nigerianos y ello a pesar de que su
elección ha sido impugnada ante los
tribunales por los partidos de la
oposición durante la campaña prometió
crear empleo a invertir en agricultura e
infraestructuras públicas pero la mejora
de la seguridad sigue siendo una de sus
principales preocupaciones mientras el
presidente saliente luchaba contra los
militantes islamistas en el noreste de
Nigeria otros grupos han surgido en
otras partes del país
me siento realizado por haber iniciado
el renacimiento de Nigeria dando los
pasos críticos iniciales Y estoy
convencido de que la administración
entrante acelerará el ritmo de esta
labor
además de la seguridad uno de los
mayores retos del presidente tinubu será
arreglar el estado de la economía
nigeriana Nigeria se enfrenta a niveles
récord de deuda altas tasas de inflación
y una moneda débil y aunque el
exgobernador de lagos ha prometido
reunir a las mejores manos para dirigir
el país los analistas se preocupan por
el nivel de responsabilidad que traerá
su administración
Nigeria también se enfrenta a los
mayores niveles de alerta de inseguridad
alimentaria y las agencias de la ONU
advierten de que es necesaria una
atención urgente para salvar vidas y
puestos de trabajo